toutes nos excuses aux je trouve sur un
jeu fait par un fan de l'attaqué des
titans vous savez je suis très fan de ce
manga death est animé regarder colossal
c'est celle là pour s'amuser
alors franchement c'est vraiment une
alfa d'une alfa du la fin je vais pas
vous mentir regarder avait pas les
textures des bâtiments c'est un simple
du tout mais ça fait quand même qui fait
vieux d'à est un mec qui travaille
depuis plus d'un an et demi sur ce jeu
vidéo puisqu'il adore attaques des
titans il veut nous faire plaisir
bref voilà il faut sauter pour ramasser
des des balises voilà exactement est en
fait le jeu sera en fête en multijoueur
ce sera en coopération ce sera nous
contre des titans faudra combler au
cours les explose oh là là là là ça
faudrait succès vu ça oh là là là là
avec ses actifs mais utile c'est
exceptionnel juste sauté utiliser le
labo 9t dimensionnelle mais en plus on
sera excellent dans le voilà en
ramassant on peut marcher sur les murs
et fantastique walhalla jacques bouya
japon ait parlé j'ai envie de chialer je
suis nul à chier objets mitchell touché
un mur avec un certain angle de caméra
pour courir sur le mur ben ouais mais ça
on sait bien ça vous avez vu ça vous
avez vu si rien ne se passait ou pas
qu'est ce que ça vous a plu
moi oui et là je dois pas touché le sol
donc c'est compliqué alors là là mais ce
style un vrai tueur de titan dans l'âme
ne me dites pas le contraire
inertie utilise ta vitesse pour tourner
autour du pilier tu mets un câble là tu
rembobine et là hop tu chopes le
deuxième au passage y est tu tournes en
l'air ce melting attaque
or pour attaquer et attaquons titan d'où
le nom et ouais ça fait chier là-dedans
presse aef tout charger attaque au riz
une ola là c'est génial et on fait des
combos on peut maintenant voir une
petite entaille dans cette nuque a tant
souffert des fumées
congratulations au merci merci alors
après il ya des courses l'oeil à deux
consommé deux courses avant c'est ok
c'est parti oh là là haut
bon dieu non gelée je les arrête arrête
ans je suis nul à chier à ces affreux ce
qui se passe dans l'animé il fait ça je
vous dis [ __ ] faites moi confiance
j'appuie vraiment sur tous les boutons
de mon clavier
on espère que ça fasse un truc stylet et
c'était évident et combientième séance
et attend pourrait 3 est carrément du
rhin station nacelle a comme ça c'est un
mec là quand ça avance et qui se disent
ça va être quoi
allez c'est parti trêve de plaisanterie
prend là là alors là là sa passion du
skill du gros ce qu'il a tout est dans
le moulinet en fait du poignet ok et
dont le moulinet delà de l'appareil de
manoeuvre tridimensionnel alors poussé
qu'ils connaissent pas la taille des
titans c'est juste un manga dans lequel
elle est l'humain l'humanité pardon j'ai
concentré c'est dur ça se fait attaquer
par des ddd titan c'est des gens qui
sont immenses qui sont un poil qui ont
pas d'organes génitaux et qui veulent te
manger rambert en passant le skill alors
voilà c'était un bref résumé dégueulasse
de l'attaquer titan mais ça fait plaisir
geof rageurs des résumés leur avance et
c'est ma passion
oh [ __ ] mais ça c'est chiant qu'on
doit mettre un à gauche et à droite mais
c'est fidèle à l'animé finalement
comment veux-tu réussir oui je fais des
vibrations avec ma boîte qui se passe
ben voilà on est non cours par terre la
y aura un titre en vrai on serait déjà
mort depuis mille ans oh lalala lalala
mais ce ce qu'ils regardent et à pleine
vitesse il arrive à bien viser quoi
c'est spectaculaire
le petit hall du temps oh la la alors là
là je me blesse c'est que je vois mon cv
direct à temps mais il est super long
cette course google a abusé
attention c'est sais mais ça va ok la
deuxième course avant celle là on va
tout donner on va faire honneur à la tag
distancer partie d'accord je pars des
noms mais je recommence mais oui gorbicz
du tout tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout est devant hu
comment tu veux l'avoir suis là c'est
beaucoup trop dur je me tourne à la
poste et jordi pas posté mon cv c'est
fini
les ballots ah oui ok excusez moi je
prends mon temps les titres taurin
olala ça c'est beau mais quand j'ai
réussi tout de suite c'est vraiment beau
et quand je prends un mur c'est bien
dégueu un titan non bien bien bien là
bien là bien là j'ai vu avec aussi nul
je suis en battant d'exploration tu te
détends direct fdp mais seulement parce
que c'est dur du coup de manoeuvrer un
peu comme dans le vrai à tahiti tant qu
ils galèrent à se faire là à la
manoeuvre tridimensionnel finish où la
femme nul rancel on n'a fait que des
français c'est bcc tient pas cela je
suis pris dans aucun bataillon là là je
finis un homme de ménage du bataillon
d'élite c'est parti il faut les mêmes
brouillé un coït saute
oh là là là là oh la la oh là là là là
même la fouine ne peut pas le stopper
oh là là là là j'ai tout qu alors là
alors là mais dieu soit loué dieu soit
herbe [ __ ] je me suis fait chier en
fait dès qu'il faut mettre un cadre ça
sauvera tard gamme la gaule je trime
écoles au port quoi c'est j'ai fait
trente secondes de moins que la première
fois on va sauver l'honneur au parcours
simple on va faire à
les titans n'ont jamais vu un mec du
bataillon et 6 nuls à ch y regarder il
va trop haut ce qu'une vraie sauterelles
moi je préfère faire droite gauche
droite gauche voyait un petit peu comme
au ski finalement oh lalala lalala
finish oh là là là là ça un skate à 6,6
assez bon d'accord si si on a à la sq on
a un diplôme
pourquoi enfin voilà que j'en sais bien
que c'est des douches et désolé c'était
très court mais ya pas plus de courses
dans la démo en tout cas j'ai hâte
vraiment que ça sorte qu'on puisse jouer
tous ensemble et buts et des petits
temps un grand merci à gaudin c'est un
lieu dans le type on était obligé ont
été obligés ne sais pas mais la vidéo ça
vous a plu aussi si vous voulez tester
le jeu le lien dans la description
n'hésitez pas
je pense que vous serez meilleurs que
moi honnêtement alors sauté dans une
prochaine vidéo je compte en temps à
montrer le jeu et puis a très vite
katmandou pis